اقف اليوم على سطحي يختي المنصور احد اضخم
ثلاث يخوت للرئيس العراقي السابق صدام
حسين هذا اليخت صنع في ثمانينيات القرن
الماضي في فنلندا وسلم الى العراق تبدو
الصوره واضحه لما ال اليه ليخت اليوم لكني
ساعود قليلا بالزمن يحدثكم كيف حصل هذا
[موسيقى]
كان المنصور يرسو في مياه الخليج في
السابق لكن صدام حسين امر بنقله الى ممر
شط العرب في اذار مارس 2003 لحمايته من
القصف الامريكي الخطه فشلت وتعرض ليخطو
للقصف ثلاث مرات لكنه لم يغرق
[موسيقى]
2003 بدا اليختو بالميلان بسبب سرقه مضخات
محركاته الضخمه ليغرق ويصبح مرتعا
للصيادين والعابرين كما نرى
[موسيقى]
كان قبل مال رئيس النظام السابق مخيف جدا
يعني حمايات
وما نقدر نوصل له اصلا من بعيد
ممنوع هسه من غرق بعد الاحداث مال 2003
ظل متروك وقمنا نجيلك استراحه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يبلغ طول المنصور 121 مترا ووزنه 7000 طن
ما يجعل الحكومه العراقيه عجزه عن انتشاله
[موسيقى]
هناك اصوات تقول ان كلفه استخراج هذا
اليخت تفوق على سعره وانا لا اعتقد يعني
هذا الموضوع فيه نسبه عاليه من الصحه هناك
اجراءات حديثه هناك دول متطوره شركات
متطوره في هذا المجال تستطيع تنظيف شط
العرب من هذه الغوارق العالقه منذ سنوات
بسبب الحروب التي شهدتها محافظه البصره
لوزاره النقل ستكون كفيله باخذ هذا هذا
اليخت واصلاحها اذا ما انتشر بطريقه صحيحه
طريقه علميه متخصصه
اتجهت كاميرا العربيه الى يخت نسيم البصره
الذي لا يقل اهميه عن المنصور والذي اصبح
متحفا يتضمن مقتنيات الرئيس السابق سمي
بياخذ القادسيه سابقا صنعته شركه دنماركيه
عام
بتكلفه بلغت اربعه اضعاف ميزانيه العراق
انذاك يبلغ طوله 82 مترا ويحتوي على مهبط
لطائرتهاليكوبتر وممرًا سريا يقود نحو
غواصه طوارئ لهذا ليختى الذي اقف فيه الان
قصه تختلف تماما عن يختي المنصور سارويها
لكم
[موسيقى]
لم يستقل صدام حسين هذا اليخت ابدا لكنه
خلق عالمه الخاص فيه كما هو حال قصوره
الرئاسيه ويتضمن اليخت الدنماركي الصناعه
اضافه لغرفه القياده غرفا للضباط والضيوف
وقاعه اجتماعات وجناح الرئاسيا خاصا به
وحده نسيم البصله دخل 2019 تقريبا
استلمته وزاره النقل
بعد
تحولت ملكيه لوزاره التعليم العالي والبحث
العلمي
جامعه البصره مركز العلوم البحار لاغراض
البحثيه والسياحيه
عام
1999 نقل اليخت الى جنوبه فرنسا تحت ملكيه
شركه هناك لتسترده الحكومه العراقيه عام
2008 بدعوه قضائيه وتحوله الى متحف ومركز
لعلوم البحار زينب المشاط صباح العربيه
البصره
[موسيقى]